Or a second look at defenses focuses on different types of defense and what they
cost.
The type of defense depends on the nature of the environmental hostility.
All defenses have costs that are expressed in tradeoffs defenses may allow
disease either because they fail to protect or because their costs are
excessive.
Costs that are acceptable to evolution may be unacceptable to patients and to
physicians.
So let's look at the nature of environmental hostility.
Some environmental factors are universal.
That's the,
that means all species and counter them.
Food,
water,
oxygen,
temperature,
pathogens,
those are things that all species or have issues with.
Others are quite specific to particular organisms,
particular predators,
particular toxins,
low oxygen at high altitude.
Those are things that not all species and counter natural environments are
actually almost never perfect.
So some environmental factors are usually suboptimal and some may actually be
life threatening.
So hostile factors can be present either continuously,
occasionally,
or periodically,
either at certain times of day or in certain seasons.
And these hostile factors that have sufficient impact on fitness will lead to
the evolution of specialized defense mechanisms.
Some defense mechanisms are universal and others are species specific for these
reasons.
So here for example,
is one kind of environmental hostility.
The smallpox virus here or hookworms on intestinal new Cosi,
a Predator and cold.
So those are all different types of factors against which certain kinds of
defense have evolved.
No,
all defenses have cost the trade off.
They evolved to protect organisms from challenges including starvation,
infection and predators.
The hostile environment,
select maintenance programs that promote survival at the expense of growth and
reproduction up to a point,
specialized defenses or specific maintenance programs.
They trade off with growth and reproduction and in general with normal
physiological functions,
those defenses are always operating at some cost
because defense is essential for reproductive success.
They have large benefits.
The acceptable cost of defense can be very large because large benefits permit
large costs.
So if we diagram these ideas,
the fitness cost of defense is the cost of the insult plus the cost of the
defense.
The environmental insult is causing a cost of the insole.
Then defense ramps up against the insole to try to reduce the cost.
It has a cost and that produces a total fitness cost and because the fences are
constrained by their costs,
the optimal defense is not the maximal defense.
In fact,
because of this equation,
fitness cost equals cost of insult clothes,
cost of defense,
the total cost of the defense can be minimized even when the cost of defense is
greater than the cost of the insole.
We all this insight to Randy Nessie we have here on the x axis is some level of
defense.
On the y axis we have a cost.
The cost of the insole is shown.
Declining here in red is the level of defense goes up.
The cost of defense is seen ramping up linearly here and we add together the red
and the blue lines.
We get the Green Line which dips down and it has a minimum right here and at
that point the cost of the defense is actually more than twice the cost of the
insole.
So cost of defense are significant and the optimal defense is not the maximal
defense.
Cost of defense have a certain structure.
Different defenses have several types of cost.
The evolutionary costs or measured is negative genetic covariances with
non-defensive functions,
so that's the usual negative genetic correlation definition of a trade off
the maintenance costs include defensive organs and tissues.
For example,
skin,
the skull,
the rib cage,
the lymphatic system.
Those are basic capital investments.
The deployment costs of induced responses involve both energetic and
physiological cost,
so they,
the energetic costs are straight forward.
You need a certain number of calories to ramp something.
Oh,
what?
The physiological cost is an interference with some other function.
Some defense mechanisms,
for example,
immune responses have additional costs such as collateral,
tissue damage,
particularly in the case of inflammation.
Inflammation.
Okay,
so how can the fences then lead to disease?
Okay.
They can do it in two ways.
They can either fail to protect or their costs can be excessive from the point
of view of the patient and the physician,
not necessarily from the point of view of evolution.
Yeah.
Whether a defense cost is excessive,
depends on the priorities of defense that is protecting from infection versus
the functions where the cost of defense are paid.
For example,
respiration or digestion in particular,
a very strong defensive reaction that could protect well against infection might
disrupt respiration or digestion.
Okay.
Costs that are acceptable in one environment can be excessive or they can be
purely detrimental in other environments.
That means that environmental change can shift the cost benefit ratio and make
costs that were acceptable earlier or elsewhere,
excessive here and now.
This is a mismatch issue,
so when do costs become unacceptable?
Yeah.
Costs that are acceptable.
From an evolutionary perspective,
we're priority is given to reproductive success are often excessive and
unacceptable to patients and physicians.
Another way of saying this is that evolution did not design us to be comfortable
and happy.
It designed us to get genes into the next generation.
Yeah.
In other words,
cost that were historically evolutionarily acceptable at the population level
can now be detrimental or excessive on an individual level.
Yeah.
These sorts of costs illustrate the striking conflicts between the interests of
conscious individuals in the interests of unconscious jeans.
Yeah.
Examples include all cases of late life disease whose risk is increased by the
anti antagonistic pleiotropic trophic effects of genes that benefit early life
survival and reproduction.
So the images elicit the early life survival and reproduction and the late life
costs.
Yeah.
So when do defenses cause disease?
The cost of defense can be the main cause of disease symptoms that's
particularly obvious with infectious disease.
Yeah.
Immunopathology is damaged,
which is caused by the immune response,
and it's the most common cause of symptoms during infections.
Okay.
Most symptoms of infectious diseases,
fever,
Anorexia,
coughing,
diarrhea,
or either expressions of defenses or reflect the costs of defense.
Okay,
so fever and these are color of feces as examples of symptoms of infection.
So when is it safe to treat a symptom that is a defense?
If you block a symptom,
that is a defense that can temporarily alleviate suffering,
but it can also interfere with the defense.
Such symptoms include fever,
Anorexia,
coughing and diarrhea.
All of these are reactions that are helping the body to handle the infection.
If the cost of defense or excessive than blocking the symptoms can relieve
suffering without negative consequences,
that would be the case if the costs are excessive.
However,
the big question is when is it safe to interfere with symptoms that are defenses
that are involved in trade offs?
And that question can only be properly answered by discovering the functions
with which the defense is trading off and they may be obscure.
So we do not always know the consequences of interfering with fever,
anorexia,
coughing and diarrhea.
The summarize environmental hostility is heterogeneous and space and variable in
time.
Defenses have costs because they participate in tradeoffs.
Tweaking them has consequences.
Defenses allowed disease either through failure to protect or through excessive
costs.
Costs may be evolutionarily acceptable or the population level,
but unacceptable to patients and physicians at the individual level.
That's a conflict.
Some costs of defense can be the main cause of disease symptoms.